you guys have done the uh Anime Cafe
with Emily right yes
how did it feel
seeing
the anime the demographic of the anime
that uh that you had watched in real
life because uh I went to the bocce The
Rock Cafe
and uh seeing African already seeing
average Bocce The Rock Fans was uh
interesting to say the least break it
down what's the demographic demographic
so I'm like watching The Rock uh Bocce
The Rock right uh walk what can I Garner
from this fan base probably probably
they're gonna be I was guessing they're
gonna be probably about my age I was
wrong they were quite a bit older we go
in line everyone is in business suits I
thought I thought I thought that we had
I thought that we were lining up for a
[__] uh katakawa meeting or something
I'm like uh Emily have you gone to the
right place we're not We're not gonna do
a Geeks plus meeting all right am I are
we I know everyone was lining up for
this bought you the Rock Cafe in like
50s in like 40s and 50s that awfully
sounds a lot like the K on Democrats
I wonder why
I thought there would be a few more
girls there I don't know
um and they were only like aside from
Emily there were only two other girls
there that uh
Emily posted a tweet of the picture of
the food put it on screen Mudan it
looked [__] vile yeah it was it was
[__] oh I don't know why of course you
vomit on that omelette like why does it
look like that I saw that and I'm not
the biggest fan of omu rice anyway uh
because I don't like ketchup and uh they
poured ketchup on it over it but somehow
they made it look even more disgusting
by just uh felt like a unicorn vomited
on it uh and they were like that's
that's the dish that's the dish guys oh
it's the pink body it's Bocce but it's
melted it's it's uh Bocce watching The
Rock and uh of course that one dish uh
we we liked to eat there you had to buy
a set meal that costed like forty
dollars that included and that was why
one of two food items uh that was like
the savory food item uh I got like the
car there was a chicken curry which has
nothing to do with Bocce The Rock just
easy to make yeah but he had Rio's face
on it so I'm like oh I guess this is uh
Bocce themed ironically enough like that
pink vomit omu rice was the only real
Bocce themed dish on there
um but I was more interested in just
looking around and seeing the kind it
was interesting going to a theme Cafe
and seeing the actual people who watched
the anime the same anime you watched
right yeah because I was asking Emily
what was the cafe that had the most
female like demographic that had the
most female viewers go to that theme
Cafe do you know what I was let me guess
some kind of like either like BL one or
something with like two boys right it
was berserk
ratio of girls guys in that Cafe and I'm
like kind of based actually uh
this is another reason why she comes to
Japan if you want to find a wife
you'll have something in common what can
I say yeah because you you ain't finding
Andy girls in like the bocce The Rock
Cafe or I'm guessing like most cute
because I was I was surprised that the
demographic was like that old you know
yeah I'm not when I went to the when I
went back when I went to the nichijo
cafe with Emily that also had quite a
few girls there as well which was also
surprising and I was like yeah because I
thought there'd be a lot more boys I
don't know I didn't I never really
thought about like the niche Joe
demographic I guess because that's kind
of like open for everyone the one that
was hilarious though was the weathering
with you cafe uh there was no one there
so that described so that describes the
demographic of that describes that demo
yeah that describes that demo
ski and I was just like oh
all right let's just order something get
the [__] out oh God yeah it was sad yeah
I still haven't been to a collab Cafe
that does good food yet I'll let you
guys know I think the nicho cafe for me
was probably the best one it was a good
food though like the food was decent
what I appreciated the one I appreciate
about the nichijo cafe is that the all
the items were actual references to the
show and they did them in really funny
ways I think I think when it comes to
themed cafes the best food I've had is
probably the Kirby Cafe I just want to
go to a place where I get as good food
as something like another good cafe or
restaurant I don't think you're going
otherwise I'm like [__] this then I'd
rather just look at pictures because
what's the [__] point I think maybe
then the Kirby Cafe might be good
because like that's a permanent store
I'm not a big fan of Kirby though I'm
kind of I know you like you look sad
so you're not a fan of happiness I see
dude Kirby's boring as [__] how [__]
day
what the [__] does Kirby do other than
just eat [__] which I can relate to uh
but he's just like come on man do
something he's just a cute little
[__] pink bull like any time when I
was a kid and I felt really [__] sad
or angry or you know just had negative
emotions I would just play a Kobe game
depression gone Kobe game as a kid and I
was like why does this [__] suck so much
oh my God it's not a game I played one
of the DS games which one it was and it
was just I was like God damn this is
like worse than every other platformer
I've ever played Kirby fans are just the
botchy The Rock Fans of the video game
industry they're just like oh look cute
pink thing doing things oh oh [__] is
that how it feels serotonin oh
I take Toby over Bocce
like Kirby is a character I think it's
height but every game but you're not a
Nintendo fan I'm like yeah I am I love
Nintendo what's your favorite Nintendo
franchise
what counts as being a Nintendo fan
right because I would say I'm a Nintendo
fan even though I don't know if I am an
internal fan I like Nintendo stuff Mario
franchise is probably the best one let's
be real yeah but that's anyone that
breathes at this point yeah but I mean
it's like it's the best like when I
think about Pokemon like there's too
many misses we think about other games
like yeah if someone says like F0 I'm
like [__] off yeah you've had this one
that's the pretentiousness two games you
haven't played it if she tells me like a
fan I'm like are you okay uh hey I like
us what's your favorite all right are
you good it's up there okay all right
let's let's Zelda I'm like
understandable no Zelda's probably the
best yeah yeah Zelda's the best okay
okay let's let's keep Nintendo for a
second let's get keep Nintendo Advance
what makes at which point does someone
become a true Nintendo fan versus just
here's some [__] I played as a kid you
know I think okay this is just my
definition of it from how I see it but
like I think it's one of those things
where it's like it's been with you all
your life and you're still heavily
involved in it right right because it's
like you know there's a lot of games
that people like you know a lot of
people especially in our age group right
grew up playing Nintendo games right it
was it was you were either like team
Sony or you were team Nintendo or team
Sega right like that that was the three
genders and like I feel like Nintendo
fans like I classify myself as a
Nintendo fan because I never touched any
of like the Sony stuff I never owned a
Sony console uh yeah I was the most
faithful I was faith I only had Nintendo
consoles growing up so I was like I play
Nintendo games all my life Nintendo
games are still like the main games that
I play yeah to this day as well so like
I would say I'm a Nintendo fan all right
A Game Fan I like get good games and
that's fine yeah like there's a lot of
other games I like as well but I think
at the end of the day I always go back
to playing Nintendo games like I was
always the Nintendo kid like yeah up to
like I am the Nintendo I
are you playing Sonic and I'm like oh
like like I would ever buy a Sega Mega
Drive are you playing Metal Gear Solid
oh what is that a PlayStation
um is that available on GameCube which
are twin Snakes was about actually
available
but uh yeah up to the GameCube I owned
nothing and I played nothing but
Nintendo games whenever someone talks
about their Nostalgia with Tony Hawks or
some [__] like that I'm like I don't get
that uh I I went to my cousin and he had
a test talk I didn't have it I didn't
like giving those away I choose like 10
bucks I did not have peer I did not have
a PS2 I was like I had this like weird
um like loyalty to Nintendo I was like
no matter what I was like no matter what
all the other kids are playing I refuse
to play anything but the GameCube I then
I became my gamer I got an Xbox 360 and
then I was like oh good games are on
other platforms as well I mean we had a
PS2 and I remember the one thing about
it was that like we should just get so
many pirated games and it made it so
much cheaper to be able to play on
playstation 2. right because Nintendo
you know they're always full price until
the GameCube kind of like tanked and
then yeah okay we've got to do a few
sales uh but yeah the PS2 games you
could just get them super easily well
I'm pretty sure my dad got like half of
them from like the pub yeah he would
just go and some guy would just give out
CDs
he was saying PlayStation drug deals at
the pump yeah I think there was just a
guy who's like yeah if you want to PS2
games
give him a 10 or 10 over like 50 games
yeah and you're like oh okay yeah I
think yeah like look like no one has the
right to like [__] determine like oh
you're a Nintendo fan you're not a
Nintendo fan it's like [__] whatever
right but like you know I think there's
nothing wrong with like you know like in
your situation where it's like you grew
up playing Nintendo games and then you
discovered other games right and and
you're playing that right yeah but I
think I don't know somewhere deep inside
of me there's still a part of me that's
just like I will always go back to
playing Nintendo game but I I find that
really interesting because I feel like
Nintendo like I I I totally get where
you're coming from because I feel like
Nintendo's the only let's say gaming
brand that has that kind of of brand
loyalty to them because you know back in
the day when there was the console war
you would have people like you know the
Xbox kid
um [__] Sony fans as well but
nowadays it's just like hardcorning
there's hardcore Nintendo fans and then
there are Gamers you know you know what
I mean like just just like there are
idle fans and music fans yeah that's
like
the same no one would one with five is
going like Oh I'm a I'm a [__]
PlayStation fan man I I believe Sony I
bullied PlayStation no one does that
during like the Wii U era it felt like
Nintendo was kind of a joke I mean they
were and everyone and everyone was kind
of like [__] Nintendo baby Nintendo
fell off they [__] fell off and then
the switch and then they came back with
the switch Yeah so it's I think the
loyalty is
will probably only keep up as long as
they keep making good games and consoles
oh of course yeah yeah and they still
make they still make great games but I
have no loyalty to their games like I
used to and I feel like some people will
play Nintendo games that doesn't care
about you guys yeah yeah but like like
we've talked about Pokemon before but
you know people are [__] loyal to
Pokemon even though comparatively to the
other franchises like Mario and Zelda I
feel like Pokemon games are a lot worse
designed and a lot worse games I've
still played every single one but that's
that's the point that's the point right
I'm like when Matt when a new Mario
comes out when a new Zelda come out
comes out I'm playing it because it's
gonna be a banger game yeah what a new
Pokemon comes out I'm like this is a 50
50 right now about whether this will
actually be a good game or not I mean
you know in saying that I haven't
enjoyed every single Pokemon game
there's been some real [__] boring
and [__] ones as well a lot of stinkers
yeah but like you know at the end of the
day whenever there's a new Pokemon game
announced I'm I'm gonna be playing it
because I'm just like I'm like this far
in I might as well [__] say it till
the end all right yeah
that's a horrible mentality yeah it's
like well you know like I also am just
like genuinely curious to see like okay
you know I've literally grown up with
this franchise my entire life like some
of my most fondest gaming memories when
I was a kid was playing [__] Pokemon
Gold and Silver on my game boy right
like right like that [__] is like but
how far can Nostalgia go
well that's the thing right and and so
like you know with the with the newest
game for example I was like I saw a lot
of merits in it but I also saw a [__]
ton of flaws in it like everybody else
did and you know as much of a Pokemon
fan as I am I can't ignore the fact that
yeah the newest game was completely
unpolished [__] rushed game yeah
right like I can't deny that but I'm
still gonna play it because I I still
see the little enjoyment that there was
in that game so to see it yeah we had
won the game come out we had this
discussion and I remember I was like do
not I I don't want to buy those games I
don't want to be like hey
let me support this practice of you
rushing out [__] all right yeah and
making it seem like it's okay because I
I just don't want to buy games that I
know are going to be like like that that
I know that are rushed because you're
kind of like supporting that almost and
obviously if that's not how you view it
that's not how you view it and it's
totally fine I'm not that's not that's
not me being like you should feel this
way it's like for me just personally I
don't want to be like hey keep making
games this way I'm like no no just take
your time yeah like a good game no no I
totally get that mentality as well but
unfortunately with Pokemon fans uh that
didn't stop no it absolutely doesn't
stop Violet and skull is still the most
sole Pokemon game ever yeah and I think
that that's more of a testament to the
switch being in more hands than ever
yeah yeah like the amount of switches
sold is insane it's like almost the most
sold console after the PS2 right I'm
pretty sure it's up there I think it's a
lot I still think it's not that much
yeah because I think the DS still if
you're out of all the DS's yeah yeah
yeah yeah but it's still it's still a
[__] ton of consoles especially in this
modern day where it doesn't a lot of the
times it doesn't really matter what
console you play because most games are
available on most consoles now anyway
especially if you have a PC
um PC gaming the most by far still yeah
it's just so easy it's so easy to PC
games I love it I mean I guess if you
haven't if you have a good PC yeah
that's the hurdle isn't it yeah like
just like you know I I also don't give a
[__] about building your own people some
people like you have to build your own
PC yeah it's a pain in the ass but just
buy one yeah you pay a little bit extra
in the parts but that's how everything
when you [__] assemble it costs by a
professional like obviously you have to
pay extra yeah yeah
um you know and it takes a lot of the
stress out of PC gaming because once you
have it it's just a PC we all know how
to use a PC people aren't like
installing games is hard come off it
steam is so goddamn easy yeah I I have
way less stress buying games on Steam
than I do on the Nintendo eShop that
[__] is like nine layers of security I
gotta enter my PayPal do you know how
horrible it is to type on the Nintendo
switch is like a console you like so you
have to put your information in every
time yeah my PayPal it makes me put it
on every time I just attached my credit
card
he got
the password
this is the kingdom in like 10 seconds
but like Steve is just so easy it's so
great I love it so much and then I love
that I can tweak the settings like like
because if there's motion blur in the
game like off with that right now right
take that off I can change the frame
rate if I want I'm like this is just
great like having this customization is
fantastic yeah uh and like you know even
though I've I've got a steam deck
recently which I like and I just I just
wish every Nintendo game I could play on
that because it's so much better yeah
it's so nice
yeah I'd like for me I would say that I
don't I now I just want a good game
because I barely have time to play games
as it is I wouldn't say I'm a Nintendo
fan because I definitely I definitely
I'm just I'm just a game for I would say
I I would say I grew out of Nintendo
actually saying that though you should
play Tears of the Kingdom no no I will
play too
like here's the thing I don't care if
it's made by Nintendo or not I just care
if it's a good game so the last you know
last games I play from Nintendo have you
know been uh Mario uh uh Odyssey Mario
Odyssey yeah it's a great game completed
that yeah to not kiss the kingdom the
breath of the wild completed that and I
know the only reason I haven't started
tears of the kingdom is because I'm
currently trying to touch grass
and and uh what's he gonna start Alden
ring there huh when are you doing Alden
ring I would I'll do it after I finish
tea as a kingdom
I'm not trying to get you Joe I know
you're not gonna play it I don't know
sometimes you should do
some sometimes I don't know sometimes
it's just a Vibe of something I like the
vibe of the whole Zelda aesthetic and
you know breath of the breath of this
[__] genetic yeah
right
was just [__] like exactly like
breath of wild yeah I just took like so
many aspects of it no wonder you like it
I know I just I the one reason I've
never completed like a soulsborne game
is that I just don't really like the oh
the reasons have changed in the past
months huh huh your reasons of [__]
you're right it went from I'm definitely
gonna play Elden ring I just gotta wait
and now you're like ah doesn't jail with
me anymore I'm like what happened guys I
am going to play because oh okay okay
okay like like he lied as easily I don't
really like the whole Dark Fantasy
setting and yeah yeah I did Dark Dark
Fantasy is just not for me uh wait you
like
that's the thing the only time I've
really got into a dark fantasy show or
story or game is when it's actually
pretty [__] good so so the product
no no so the product has to be good
enough to make me to to get over that
hump that it is a dark fantasy setting
right so I know Eldon ring fits in that
category which is why I know I'm gonna
play it it just like it just takes that
extra bit of push to be like oh you
should get into this game because I
don't really like Dark Fantasy stuff I'm
more like a Sci-Fi kind of like person
or what if you streamed it
the push that you're making content and
you're finally playing that game you
wanted to play
do I do I want to do that though you
could go the dinosaurs and streamer for
15 hours maybe make content out of it
you know like honkai and genshin are
just turn your brain off and kind of do
whatever I would have to like actually
be a gamer if I did Delvin ring you know
I don't know if I'm prepared for that
guys I forgot he's a hoverse fan
I'm a horrible streamer there is a
difference man they sponsored you and
then they they made such a good
investment they locked you in for life
just a few few lump stump payments yeah